Le notifiche push, consapevolmente o meno, le usiamo tutti quanti, ogni giorno, anche
decine di volte al giorno. Ci avvisano quando qualcuno ci invia un messaggio, ci ricordano
i movimenti delle nostre carte di credito, ci segnalano una news che potrebbe interessarci
o l'ultimo video del nostro youtuber preferito o un tweet di tendenza e molto molto altro
ancora. Ma quanti di noi sanno che queste utilissime notifiche si basano su un meccanismo
che nasconde un potenziale incubo per la privacy degli utenti che le ricevono? Ne parliamo
fra pochissimo, dopo la sigla.
La notizia che mi ha fatto pensare di realizzare questo episodio risale ormai a qualche settimana
fa ed il motivo per cui mi interessa riprenderla è che, come a volte accade, essa ha fatto
conoscere al grande pubblico qualcosa che per gli addetti ai lavori era già abbastanza
ovvio e noto da tempo e semplicemente volevo rifletterci un po' su con te. Nello specifico
sto parlando del fatto che il meccanismo che permette il funzionamento delle cosiddette
notifiche push per smartphone e computer permette anche a chi gestisce il sistema
di invio di risalire all'utenza ed al dispositivo che riceve le comunicazioni e se questo fatto,
detto in questo modo, ti può suonare abbastanza ovvio, beh sappi che a quanto si è visto
non lo è per tutti. Partiamo quindi dall'inizio e vediamo innanzitutto cosa è successo, poi
come è potuto succedere e infine quali sono le implicazioni di tutta la faccenda e nel
farlo proviamo anche a capire un po' come funzionano le notifiche push. Alla fine di
febbraio di quest'anno il Washington Post ha pubblicato un articolo il cui titolo era,
lo dico in italiano, la nuova tattica dell'FBI, catturare i sospetti con le notifiche push.
In tale articolo è raccontata la storia di come alcuni agenti federali abbiano identificato un
utente che scambiava contenuti pedopornografici richiedendo a Google di rintracciarlo tramite
le notifiche push che riceveva. L'uomo in questione agiva in anonimato ovviamente ed
utilizzava anche un'app svizzera di messaggistica chiamata Teleguard le cui comunicazioni sono
private e criptografate, ma ciò non è bastato ad impedire a Google di identificarlo e di
consegnare le sue informazioni nelle mani degli inquirenti. A seguito di questa scoperta però
il Washington Post ha poi indagato ulteriormente e ha trovato almeno 130 casi in cui è stata
utilizzata questa tecnica per individuare sospetti con l'aiuto di Google, Apple o Facebook. Alcuni
di questi casi risalgono anche a vari anni fa e per la precisione iniziano dal 2019.
Ma come è possibile che Google, Apple o chi che sia possa rintracciare un utente tramite
le notifiche inviate al suo dispositivo? Un utente che addirittura utilizza sistemi di
messaggistica criptati che in teoria dovrebbero essere totalmente sicuri e anonimi? Beh in realtà
conoscendo un po' come funzionano i sistemi per l'invio di notifiche push la risposta non è poi
così complicata. Piccola nota, essendomi capitato in passato di implementare soluzioni di notifica
per siti web tramite servizi di Google, in questo episodio ti parlerò nello specifico di come
funziona questo sistema, ma i concetti di base valgono anche per Apple, Facebook o qualunque
altro soggetto che possieda un proprio sistema di notifiche push. Cominciamo col dire che le
notifiche push non nascono certo come un metodo di tracciamento ma sono un meccanismo pensato
per rendere più efficiente l'invio delle notifiche agli utenti. Considerando infatti quante app sono
installate sui nostri dispositivi e quante notifiche esse generano ogni giorno, l'idea di
base è raggruppare tutte queste interazioni in flussi di comunicazione ottimizzati e farli
partire da un numero minimo di server. In pratica invece di attendere che ogni app o sito web si
colleghi al proprio server per richiedere le novità in sospeso, il sistema delle notifiche
push invia immediatamente al dispositivo ciascuna notifica appena questa è disponibile,
a prescindere dall'app o dal sito cui essa è destinata. Questa, raccontata così molto alla
buona, è in sostanza la soluzione implementata dai maggiori player del mondo informatico, Google,
Apple, Meta e compagni, e utilizzata quasi da tutte le app e siti in circolazione. Il punto
però è che per far funzionare un sistema del genere è necessario che il gestore del server
conosca gli account degli utenti e i dispositivi presso i quali andranno inviate le notifiche,
nonché le app, i siti di destinazione e tutti i dettagli da mostrare nell'anteprima. Per poter
consegnare ad un utente una notifica infatti bisogna identificare su quali dispositivi egli
è registrato e bisogna anche avere un collegamento a tali dispositivi in tempo quasi reale e inviare
tutte le informazioni necessarie specificando l'app o il sito di turno ed il contenuto del
banner che dovrà essere mostrato. Ora tu avrai certamente notato che ogni volta che installi
un'app sul tuo smartphone o tablet questa ti richiede il permesso di poterti mostrare le
notifiche così come spesso fanno anche tanti siti web di notizie o con funzioni social e di
messaggistica. Beh quella richiesta non è solo un'autorizzazione ma sottintende anche tutto un
procedimento di configurazione che ha luogo tra il tuo dispositivo e i server del gestore del
sistema push. In pratica accade che il dispositivo segnala al server la propria esistenza chiedendo
di essere avvisato immediatamente in caso siano presenti nuove notifiche riguardo quella specifica
app o sito web e insieme i due sistemi concordano e si scambiano alcune stringhe di testo che
servono per il funzionamento di tutto il meccanismo. Una di queste stringhe è il push token che è unico
per ciascuna tripletta composta da dispositivo utente e sito oppure app e rappresenta una sorta
di password potremmo dire che il dispositivo deve utilizzare per ottenere le notifiche che lo
riguardano. Una seconda stringa importante poi è il codice identificativo di argomento che a seconda
dei casi ha vari utilizzi ma semplificando molto diciamo che nel caso delle app di messaggistica
permette di identificare i dispositivi del destinatario di una o più notifiche. Volendo
essere un po' più precisi in realtà il codice argomento identifica una tipologia di informazione
sulla quale l'utente è interessato a ricevere aggiornamenti nel più breve tempo possibile e
quando dispositivo e server push si accordano sulla ricezione di notifiche l'app o il sito di
turno specificano a quali argomenti scrivere l'utente e quindi per quali novità riceverà
le notifiche. Quando si parla di app di messaggistica ogni chat coincide bene o male
con un certo argomento e quindi di fatto ogni chat privata tra due utenti permette di risalire ai due
tramite i codici argomento ad essa collegati e dico codici e non codice perché ciascun utente
avrà il proprio pur essendo la chat in comune tra i due. Ad ogni modo il concetto è che grazie a
push token e codice argomento ogni dispositivo può restare in ascolto presso un server push che
per android sarà ad esempio google e per iphone sarà apple e al tempo stesso il server di ciascuna
app può comunicare al server push di riferimento i dati delle notifiche da inoltrare e gli utenti
a cui inoltrarle. Per i siti web la questione è un pelo più complicata perché è il browser
a dover tenere il collegamento verso i server push che potenzialmente potrebbero anche essere
più di uno ma anche in questo caso al momento questi dettagli non ci interessano. Ciò che invece
dobbiamo tenere bene a mente per capire le implicazioni in termini di privacy di tutto
questo sistema è il ciclo di vita di una notifica push che più o meno è il seguente. 1 le notifiche
comprensive di tutti i relativi dettagli, quelli che compaiono nelle anteprime per intenderci,
vengono generate dal server originale di un app o di un sito. 2 tale server poi contatta
i server del servizio di notifica push che come abbiamo già detto solitamente appartengono a
google o apple o qualche altro big. Indica tutte le informazioni da recapitare e il codice argomento
relativo. 3 il server push combina insieme il codice argomento e l'identità del server che lo
ha appena contattato e così facendo identifica l'app e il dispositivo o i dispositivi del o dei
destinatari iscritti all'argomento e gli invia tutto il necessario. 4 una volta recapitate le
informazioni nel caso di un app viene mostrato il classico banner di notifica del sistema
operativo mentre nel caso di un sito la gestione può anche essere un po più personalizzata. Come di
consueto tecnicamente parlando in realtà tutto il giro è un po più complicato di così ma per quello
che ci interessa i passaggi descritti sono perfetti. Tornando infatti alla nostra domanda iniziale su
come si può rintracciare un utente tramite le notifiche. Dobbiamo per forza presupporre che il
server del servizio push debba in qualche modo archiviare una lista di tutti gli utenti dei
dispositivi collegati e delle app e dei siti per poter mettere in funzione tutto il meccanismo
quando necessario. Il succo della questione in pratica è che se ad esempio il server delle
notifiche push deve consegnare le informazioni ricevute da whatsapp per la chat x che ricordiamo
corrisponde a un certo argomento y deve cercare all'interno dei propri elenchi l'identificativo
degli utenti collegati all'app di whatsapp per l'argomento y ed estrarre i corrispondenti
dispositivi altrimenti semplicemente non può fare il suo lavoro. In definitiva quindi ora
dovrebbe essere chiaro che il server delle notifiche push è contemporaneamente a conoscenza
di tutta una serie di informazioni che vanno dall'account dell'utente al dispositivo che sta
utilizzando alle app e ai siti che frequenta e per cui riceve notifiche e cosa non da poco
alle informazioni contenute in queste notifiche banalmente le anteprime dei messaggi. Ora data
la complessità e la pervasività e l'importanza di un sistema come quello appena descritto non
possiamo certo pensare che non implementi tutta una serie di log da utilizzare in caso di verifica
e di reportistica sarebbe folle se non lo facesse è un servizio attivo a livello mondiale che serve
ogni giorno centinaia di milioni di utenti e tali log devono contenere certamente identificativi e
informazioni inviate dai server delle app e dei siti nonché probabilmente l'esito di consegna
delle notifiche e altri dati utili sia a fini statistici che di manutenzione. A questo punto
ci tengo ad essere chiaro io non ho trovato articoli online che illustrassero esplicitamente
la procedura utilizzata da google per fornire le informazioni all'fbi del caso di cui stiamo
parlando o altri simili ma a questo punto con quello che ci siamo detti finora possiamo provare
ad immaginare i passi seguiti poi se qualcuno ne sa di più su questo argomento potrà tranquillamente
confermare o smentire le seguenti supposizioni. Immaginiamo di avere la possibilità di consultare
i log dei server delle notifiche push di google come potremmo fare ad individuare l'identità di
uno specifico utente che stiamo monitorando su una chat una qualsiasi whatsapp telegram teleguard
un'idea potrebbe essere quella di fare arrivare all'utente una serie di notifiche con caratteristiche
uniche in questo modo potremo poi andare a ricercarle all'interno dei log ed usarle per
individuare un codice argomento a cui è iscritto l'utente ad esempio gli potremmo spedire messaggi
contenenti specifiche stringhe di testo abbastanza complesse da essere potenzialmente uniche e
abbastanza brevi da rientrare nell'anteprima della notifica oppure potremmo spedirgli una serie di
messaggi con un particolare pattern temporale ad esempio generando un preciso numero di notifiche
in un arco di tempo ben definito in entrambi questi casi avendo accesso ai log del server
push potremmo poi effettuare delle ricerche ed individuare con buona approssimazione l'utente
a cui abbiamo inviato le nostre notifiche e trappola l'identificativo dell'argomento salvo
eventi eccezionali sarà sempre uguale per tutte le notifiche inviate all'utente per quella particolare
chat e pertanto fungerà da elemento comune tra i risultati della ricerca negli archivi in pratica
le ricerche saranno qualcosa del tipo estraiamo tutti gli identificativi per cui sono state
inviate notifiche push contenenti la stringa trappola spedita via chat il giorno tot alle ore
tot oppure estraiamo tutti gli identificativi per cui sono state inviate notifiche push alla
seguente data e ora e specifichiamo tutti gli orari dei messaggi che gli abbiamo spedito a
questo punto non ci resterà che accedere al database dei server push e individuare i dispositivi e
quindi gli utenti iscritti a ricevere notifiche dai codici argomento venuti fuori dalle nostre
query di ricerca e semplicemente il gioco è fatto le probabilità di trovare più di un utente che
corrisponda ai risultati della ricerca saranno relativamente basse ma anche in caso contrario
sarà possibile poi completare le indagini in modo tradizionale per l'fbi infatti un conto e
non avere idea di chi si sta cercando tutt'altra cosa invece è dover indagare su un numero molto
ristretto di sospetti quale che sia effettivamente la tecnica utilizzata da google e dall'fbi quel
che è certo è che è stata essenziale per catturare un criminale quindi ad una prima impressione può
sembrare un'ottima cosa riflettendoci un po più a fondo però la notizia è anche piuttosto preoccupante
questa sorta di indagine del washington post ha suscitato più di una perplessità perché in effetti
ha fatto emergere un meccanismo di sorveglianza di massa da parte di grandi nomi come google o
apple che è in piedi ormai da anni e se in generale la sorveglianza di massa non è mai una buona idea
è ancora peggio quando è messa in atto da soggetti privati tanto per cominciare finché la tecnica
dell'individuazione tramite notifiche push viene utilizzata dalle forze dell'ordine dei governi
democratici diciamo che potrebbe ancora andarci bene ma il problema come sempre nasce quando
questi meccanismi sono nelle mani di entità diversamente democratiche oltretutto noi magari
oggi possiamo essere d'accordo con chi è al potere ma ciò non implica che lo saremo sicuramente anche
domani e la presenza di un meccanismo così pervasivo per scovare le persone potrebbe diventare un
grosso problema sia google che apple hanno dichiarato che se fino ad ora non lo facevano
già per il futuro pretenderanno sempre un'ingiunzione del tribunale per effettuare questo tipo di
controlli sui dati dei propri utenti ma come ben sappiamo questa è una blanda rassicurazione
accentrare tante informazioni in un unico punto le rende molto desiderabili da parte di chi pensa
di poterne ricavare vantaggio o addirittura profitto sia legalmente che illegalmente inoltre
google o apple o qualsiasi altra società non sono entità monolitiche ma sono fatte di migliaia di
persone il fatto che un'azienda dichiari di tenere al sicuro dei dati non implica necessariamente
che ogni singola persona al suo interno non possa decidere di fare qualcosa di stupido con
quei dati in tutto questo comunque noi utenti non possiamo fare praticamente più nulla per
evitare di essere sottoposti a questa sorveglianza passiva se non iniziare a rifiutare ogni tipo di
notifica futura e magari scegliere dispositivi privi di notifiche push con però tutti gli svantaggi
del caso al momento infatti esistono degli smartphone con sistemi operativi open source e
senza servizi google o apple ma difficilmente possono essere pensati per un uso da parte di
chiunque perché hanno delle limitazioni e richiedono che l'utente abbia un minimo di
competenza senza contare che poi le notifiche push sono molto comode e utili e in ogni caso
una misura del genere non risolverebbe nemmeno il problema in toto ma solo per le app e i siti
che utilizzeremo in futuro per quelle già autorizzate ormai il danno è fatto se anche
infatti disattivassimo totalmente le notifiche push questo non ci assicurerebbe la rimozione
degli identificativi e la completa disconnessione dei vari servizi già registrati né tanto meno
il mancato invio delle notifiche da parte di questi ultimi in tal caso infatti il flusso di
notifica si interromperebbe una volta arrivato sul server push non a monte sul server che origina
i dati e ce li spedisce quindi noi non vedremmo le notifiche ma saremmo comunque individuabili
esattamente come se le ricevessimo normalmente per capirci riprendendo l'esempio di prima se
disattivassimo le notifiche di whatsapp il server dell'app di messaggistica potrebbe continuare a
mandare notifiche ai server di google e apple e sarebbero poi questi ultimi a non recapitarle al
nostro dispositivo pur però continuando a ricevere tutte le informazioni necessarie per identificarci
insomma come affermato già un anno fa da parte dell'esperto di privacy david libo in un articolo
piuttosto interessante sull'argomento le notifiche push sono un incubo per la privacy trovi sempre il
link in descrizione ma è proprio impossibile difendersi da questo sistema di sorveglianza
di massa beh guardando all'esempio di prima in verità no qualcosa si può fare prima è un app di
messaggistica svizzera che pone particolare enfasi sul rispetto della privacy e della sicurezza dei
propri utenti i suoi sviluppatori al corrente già da tempo del problema delle notifiche push hanno
deciso di implementare per la propria app un sistema di notifiche push ad hoc utilizzando
dei server propri e senza appoggiarsi a quelli dei giganti di big tech in tal modo l'azienda ha
il pieno controllo su tutti gli aspetti delle notifiche dall'archiviazione alla codifica e
tutte le informazioni vengono protette da intrusioni esterne nel caso te lo stessi chiedendo
questo non vuol dire che l'app è diventata il ritrovo di criminali e terroristi perché il fatto
di tenere al sicuro i dati da occhi indiscreti non vuol dire non collaborare con le forze
dell'ordine quando richiesto vuol dire solo decentralizzare le informazioni e fare in modo
che esse non siano alla merce di chiunque in pratica anche se l'app prima gira su piattaforme
come pc windows o smartphone android il fatto che la comunicazione avvenga tramite i server
privati dell'azienda permette di non utilizzare i push token e i codici argomento di google o di
microsoft in tal modo la comunicazione è protetta e sottratta alla sorveglianza di massa se anche
qualcuno entrasse in possesso delle informazioni di Threema infatti al massimo potrebbe arrivare a
conoscere l'account Threema dell'utente e i dati in possesso dell'azienda ma non li potrebbe
collegare ad altre informazioni su altre app utilizzate da questa persona o installate sul
suo dispositivo il concetto in pratica è quello di separare i flussi delle notifiche push se ogni
app utilizzasse il proprio server push tutte le informazioni resterebbero separate e raccoglierle
a strascico sarebbe molto più complicato per chi non è autorizzato a farlo purtroppo a causa
delle restrizioni apple tutto questo discorso per ora non è applicabile su iphone ma il caso Threema
resta comunque un esempio virtuoso che se seguito da tanti sarebbe un'ottima soluzione per migliorare
la protezione della privacy di tutti noi utenti prima di concludere l'episodio oggi ho un piccolo
annuncio da fare se usi google podcast spero saprai che l'app sta per essere dismessa e a
breve entrerà a far parte del famigerato cimitero di google quindi ti consiglio di passare ad altre
app trovi pensieri in codice su tutte le migliori app di podcast o su youtube music se sei
particolarmente affezionato ai prodotti google detto questo ti ricordo che ormai da qualche
mese pensieri in codice aderisce alla filosofia value for value il che vuol dire che non sentirai
pubblicità e non sarai tracciato o tracciata e le tue informazioni non saranno distribuite in giro
ma tu puoi scegliere liberamente se e come restituire il valore che senti di ottenere da
questo progetto in pratica se ti dispiacerebbe se pensieri in codice non ci fosse se per te
questo podcast ha un valore quanto grande lo decidi tu allora puoi scegliere di ricompensarlo con una
delle tre t time talent o treasure cosa vuol dire vuol dire che io mi impegno a portare avanti il
progetto al meglio delle mie possibilità e tu in cambio puoi dedicare un po del tuo tempo ad esempio
puoi parlarne e farlo ascoltare a qualcuno che pensi che possa apprezzarlo puoi scrivere una
recensione su itunes o su qualche altro servizio puoi citarlo nei tuoi contenuti e eccetera oppure
puoi mettere al servizio il tuo talento sai programmare puoi aiutare con i servizi e gli
automatismi o a sistemare qualche parte del sito sai gestire i social puoi farti carico di uno
o più aspetti collegati alla diffusione o puoi cimentarti con qualsiasi altro talento proponi
direttamente tu cosa ad esempio in questi giorni francesco e antonio mi hanno aiutato tantissimo
il primo con la creazione delle trascrizioni e delle locandine e il secondo sviluppando
automatismi per la pubblicazione di news nel gruppo telegram e infine la terza t sta per
treasure cioè puoi fare una donazione che aiuti a coprire le spese che un progetto del genere
porta che non sono poche se pensi che spaziano dai costi delle attrezzature e dei servizi fino
al mio impegno in termini di tempo e a questo proposito un grande ringraziamento va come
sempre ad edoardo e carlo che se non sbaglio a breve arriveranno a due anni come donatori fissi
grazie ragazzi e niente il sito pensieri in codice punto it ormai lo conosci e ci trovi tutte le
informazioni che ti possono servire se vuoi scrivermi unirti alla community fare donazioni
eccetera noi ci sentiamo al prossimo episodio e tu non dimenticare mai che un informatico risolve
problemi a volte anche usando il computer